All right guys, so here is the last example.
You can see the ancient session ended here.
We have our BUI right here.
So I wait for price to come back into our BUI,
which happens right here.
I drop down to one minute.
And I look for my market structure shift.
Happens just right here.
I would take my entry from it.
Actually, I would take my entry from this level
because they are very close to each other.
And also if I drag this along,
you might remember my autoblock fake out,
autoblock liquidity trading strategy.
So you see we had a small little change of factor here.
And you can see price went down
and now it's pushed back up again.
Now this old autoblock is
has BPR, this autoblock.
So this is like the best area for me to enter off of.
So I would take my entry here,
put my stop probably right here,
just below the body right here.
And I would target probably this level right here.
Sure, but let's see how this plays out.
So we get a beautiful entry right here.
And price, did it hit or take profit?
It did not, it just simply reacted off this fairly gap.
So in a normal condition, I would look for one to two,
but this was, this could have been 2.5 easily.
But if you probably held, yep.
So actually it just went ahead
and took out this take profit level.
And I believe it takes out the Asian high as well.
Okay, I don't think so.
I'm not sure.
Let's see, let's see.
Up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, go up, go up.
Nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope,
nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope,
okay, nevermind.
So yeah, this would have been actually
one to three risk reward trade guys.
It's really simple, mechanical trading strategy
that you can use.
I hope you guys enjoyed
and took some knowledge off of this course update.
As I said before,
there are gonna be a lot of course updates in the future.
And you're gonna get that for absolutely free.
I'm just gonna keep on updating the course,
uploading more videos
because IT content is too big guys.
And even if I spend like a week
constantly making videos again and again,
it's not gonna be enough.
So I need time.
So I'll try to upload more videos after each month,
I would say.
But anyways, if you have any questions,
let me know and I'll answer them.
And goodbye, take care, love you guys.